more governments are kicking people off
the internet than ever before it usually
happens during politically sensitive
times like elections protests and
conflicts last year government's shut
down the internet more frequently than
in previous years according to a digital
rights group that started tracking the
practice in 2011 for instance in India
it happened in parts of the country more
than a hundred times
authorities say shutdowns helped stop
unrest and the spread of fake news and
even prevent cheating on school exams
advocates for an open Internet say
shutdowns can [ __ ] economies and
disrupt daily life all while curtailing
civil rights so here's how governments
can kick you off the internet usually
when you type in a URL or hit an app
icon the domain name system looks up
that address and resolves it to a string
of pre assigned numbers in under a
second you can usually connect to the
server and access a site if the
government wants to block access to a
specific site it can request the
Internet service provider to interfere
with the DNS traffic the provider can
then redirect traffic so it never
reaches those servers this happened last
year at the height of a political crisis
in Venezuela when opposition leader Juan
Guido tried to seize power from
President Nicolas Maduro Guido was
standing with soldiers outside a
military base when he began
live-streaming on Twitter momentum in
women book is how order he called people
to rise up against President Nicolas
Maduro while Guido is called to action
ricocheted across the world at home his
message was blocked for a large number
of Internet users this chart shows that
Venezuela state-run internet provider
restricted access to social media the
company didn't respond to a request for
comment we're looking at something
similar to radio censorship or TV
censorship when bleep out part of a
sentence or a speech opt ocher is a
founder of an internet advocacy group
called net blocks
he says it's surprisingly easy for the
government to turn off access to
specific sites this is basically an
engineer with a button on the switch
when they see something they don't like
they press the button
but authorities can be more subtle in
how they control the internet not just
by blocking sites but by simply slowing
down the connection this is called
throttling so it looks like your apps
are still running when in fact the
interference is at a level that makes
using the internet painful so the video
you're trying to watch on YouTube
becomes very low res or it keeps loading
we spoke to network engineers who
monitor internet censorship and they say
that it's even hard for them to really
pinpoint the specific reason behind a
slow connection and they say that's
likely why some governments have turned
to throttling to shrug off
accountability in some extreme cases
governments can order service providers
to turn off the internet completely this
happened last year during
anti-government protests in Iraq when
the internet was cut off you connect the
Wi-Fi and open the browser
there is nothing and provider send us
some messages we are sorry because the
government cut off the internet a mere
Hazim is an Iraqi photographer in
Baghdad and he's been posting his photos
on Instagram the Iraqi Prime Minister at
the time said it's the government's
right to restrict access when the
Internet is being used to stoke violence
and conspiracy against the homeland
because internet blackouts disrupt
critical services and can hurt the
economy authorities often target
specific networks and geographic areas
at the height of the protests in Iraq
the government imposed daily digital
curfews between 5 p.m. to 7 a.m. then
during business hours the government
ordered service providers to turn on the
connection again we spoke to private
companies in several countries and they
say they have little power to refuse a
request because authorities can threaten
to terminate their licenses citizens
have looked for workarounds like using
VPNs that connected networks outside of
the country some will pay for expensive
satellite connections others like Hazim
have bought international SIM cards from
Jordan that are activated before
entering Iraq
that helped us to keep people updated I
start doing lies from the hill square
showing the area around and what's
happening really and how people are
living and how the government are using
violence toker says these solutions may
end up encouraging more aggressive news
from the government the more people
attempt to get around it the more
governments are going to try to switch
it off the UN says restrictions on
Internet access
are a violation of Human Rights but many
countries already have laws that make it
legal to shut down the internet on
grounds related to national security or
stopping the spread of fake news so
while this might have started off as
authoritarian dictatorship move it gets
encoded into laws it becomes very
difficult for the public to complain
about it
[Music]